[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend ihnen allen
und willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem Montag die vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir der neue Premier
Großbritanniens steht fest
Machtwechsel ohne macht Kampf die
britischen Konservativen entscheiden
sich für Ex-Finanzminister Richi sunack
als künftigen Vorsitzenden und
Regierungschef
wieder Aufbauhilfe für die Ukraine
deutschland und andere westliche Staaten
sammeln Geld für die Zeit nach dem Krieg
und wie weiter mit den corona-maßnahmen
Deutschlands Gesundheitsminister
überprüfen die impf- und maskenpflicht
in einzelnen Bereichen
[Musik]
die britischen Konservativen haben nun
doch überraschend schnell einen neuen
Parteichef und damit auch
Premierminister gefunden zum ersten Mal
kommt ein Mann ins Amt der nicht weiß
ist und der als Hindu einer ethnischen
Minderheit angehört
42 Jahre alt Sohn indischer Einwanderer
sehr vermögend ehemaliger
Investmentbanker er ist als einziger
Bewerber der Tories übrig geblieben und
muss jetzt das Land aus der Krise führen
aus London Yassin hairline
und auf einmal ist alles Jubel und pure
Freude als sei nichts gewesen
Großbritanniens konservative feiern
ihren bereits dritten Premierminister im
Jahr 2022 Regie sunak
es besteht kein Zweifel dass wir uns
einer großen wirtschaftlichen
Herausforderung stellen müssen wir
brauchen jetzt Stabilität und Einigkeit
und ich werde es zu meiner allerhöchsten
Priorität machen unsere Partei und unser
Land zu einem
möglich geworden war die Kühe des
ehemaligen Finanzministers allerdings
erst durch den Rückzug Boris Johnsons
der hatte übers Wochenende noch einmal
kräftig für Wirbel gesorgt dann aber
erklärt es sei nun doch nicht der
richtige Zeitpunkt noch einmal
anzutreten so viel Vernunft und
Uneigennützigkeit verblüfft dann selbst
alte Weggefährten die aber trotzdem nach
und nach zu sunak überliefen
er wird gut und effizient regieren und
vor allem mit mehr Ruhe denn das ist was
die Menschen im Land und hier in meinem
Wahlkreis wollen
leb noch die aktuelle Ministerin für
Unterhaus Angelegenheiten Penny mordent
sie zog dann ebenfalls ihre Kandidatur
zurück wohl weil sie nicht die nötige
Anzahl Stimmen hatte ganz gleich wer
jetzt Premierminister ist dieser Person
fehlt die Legitimation meint die
Opposition das ist jetzt der fünfte
Premierminister in sechs Jahren wir
hatten vier Finanzminister in vier
Monaten das ist nicht unser Land wie wir
es kennen das ist Chaos und viele werden
denken um Himmels Willen gibt uns
wenigstens die Wahl
doch Parlamentswahlen wird es
möglicherweise erst in zwei Jahren geben
sollte es premise
holen wir Andreas Stamm in London dazu
was sind jetzt die drängsten Aufgaben
für den neuen Premier
ja ich würde mal drei rausstellen zum
einen erstens die Partei ein denn das
war mehr ein Hühnerhaufen als eine
politische Partei in diesen sechs Wochen
Amtszeit liststraße eine völlige
Selbstzerstörung inklusive
Handgreiflichkeiten im Parlament
zweitens Stabilität bringen vor allem in
Sachen Wirtschaftspolitik denn der Kurs
von List Trust dieses Experiment Steuern
senken mitten in einer Wirtschaftskrise
das ganze auf Pump dafür Schulden machen
das hat zu einem Beben an den
Finanzmärkten geführt und das hat den
Wirtschafts- und Finanzstandort
Großbritannien wirklich erheblich
geschädigt und drittens ja die Tories
aus dem tiefsten umfragekeller
rausführen das wird nicht einfach und
viele beschreiben das was wichtig ist
als ein Höllen Job große Herausforderung
wie beliebt ist er bei den Briten
er war extrem beliebt als Finanzminister
während der Pandemie da hat er Hunderte
Milliarden ausgeteilt und diese Liebe ja
die rostete ganz schnell als er dann
wenn ich später sagen muss sie aber
jetzt nur noch die Steuern erhöhen und
das Geld wieder zurückzuholen und dann
kam dazu dass seine Frau ja Erben und
Tochter eines der reichsten indischen
industriellen keine oder kaum Steuern in
Großbritannien gezahlt hat aufgrund
eines ja sonderstatuses und da war es
mit der Liebe vorbei mittlerweile gilt
allerdings alles ist besser als List
Trust zumindest in weiten Teilen der
britischen Öffentlichkeit und aber ist
das begeisterungsstürmer auslöst dieser
neue Premierminister da ist auch noch
ein weiter Weg die Einschätzung von
Andreas Stamm aus London vielen Dank
seit acht Monaten ist Krieg in der
Ukraine ein Ende nicht absehbar dennoch
da sind sich viele Politiker einig gilt
es schon jetzt den Wiederaufbau
voranzutreiben darum geht es beim
deutsch-ukrainischen Wirtschaftsforum in
Berlin am wichtigsten ist die
Energieversorgung die schnellstmöglich
wieder funktionieren muss außerdem sind
Straßen Brücken und schienen wieder
instand zu setzen auch damit
ausländische Investoren ins Land kommen
Klaus Brodbeck berichtet
immer mehr immer schwerer 750 Milliarden
Dollar schätzt die Regierung in Kiew
mittlerweile wird es brauchen die
Schäden zu beseitigen und das Land
zugleich zu modernisieren beim Treffen
in Berlin wird der Ministerpräsident um
Investitionen in sein Land
dieser Wandel eröffnet unglaubliche
Möglichkeiten für europäische
Unternehmen im Energiebereich in der
Landwirtschaft im Militärbereich bei der
IT in allen Bereichen kann die Ukraine
Plattform für neues werden
Deutschland werde die Ukraine
unterstützen solange dies notwendig sei
versichert der Bundeskanzler auch nach
einem Ende des Krieges wir wollen dass
die Ukraine Teil der Europäischen Union
wird
diese Entscheidung sendet auch ein
Signal an private Investoren wer heute
in den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
investiert der investiert in ein
künftiges EU-Mitgliedsland das Teil sein
wird unser Rechtsgemeinschaft und
unseres Binnenmarkts ein Wiederaufbau
und Weiterentwicklung der Ukraine will
sich auch die deutsche Wirtschaft
beteiligen so schnell wie möglich trotz
andauernder Gefechte
sie können auf die Erfahrung
Unterstützung der deutschen Unternehmen
zählen die bereits seit vielen Jahren in
der Ukraine tätig sind und die er
Möglichstes unternommen haben um die
dortige Produktion aufrecht zu erhalten
aufgeben war und ist keine Option eine
internationale wiederaufbaukonferenz von
EU und G7 soll morgen weitere Hilfen für
die Ukraine beraten der Winter rückt
näher
investieren in der Ukraine das scheint
im Moment eine fast absurde Idee unsere
Reporter daran hat in Odessa einen
deutschen Unternehmer getroffen der dem
Land großes Potenzial bescheinigt
er ist schon in Odessa Michael Löffler
arbeitet seit Jahren für die Firma ocam
Mithilfe künstlicher Intelligenz
analysieren sie große Datenstrukturen zu
Beginn des Krieges hat er innerhalb von
20 Minuten gepackt und ist über
Moldawien geflüchtet denn Wiederaufbau
begrüßt er ich würde mich auch sehr
freuen wenn eben dabei nicht nur Kiew im
Zentrum steht sondern eben auch der Rest
des Landes nicht ganz aus den Augen
gerät weil gerade für deutsche Firmen
sind die Lohnkosten außerhalb von Kiew
noch mal deutlich niedriger zum Beispiel
als in Kiel selbst ohne Krieg könnte die
Ukraine ihre Trümpfe als
Wirtschaftsstandort voll ausspielen
niedrigolohnkosten gut ausgebildete
Arbeitskräfte und eine Digitalisierung
die sich Deutschland als Vorbild nehmen
könnte also es gibt mittlerweile diese
dia-app wo zum Beispiel Ukraine ihre
ihre ich AGs komplett elektronisch
anmelden können das ganze Verfahren mit
elektronischen Signaturen ist weit
eingeführt mittlerweile und also der
Prozess läuft gut und schnell voran und
ist auch schon weit fortgeschritten
selbst im Krieg ist der IT-Sektor weiter
funktionsfähig doch die Industrie darbt
tausende Arbeiter sind an der Front
Lieferketten unterbrochen
schwierig wird es für die klassische
Industrie für ihre Produktion braucht es
eine stabile Stromversorgung ein
Schienen und Straßennetz das
funktioniert und all das ist weitgehend
zerstört der Wiederaufbau wird
Milliarden kosten und im Krieg sehr
risikoreich sein denn das neu aufgebaute
könnte wieder zerstört werden
in Berlin war heute Staffelübergabe der
bisherige ukrainische Botschafter andre
Melnik wurde nach fast acht Jahren
offiziell von seinem Nachfolger abgelöst
auf Schloss Bellevue wurde olexime von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier im neuen Amt
begrüßt
marques spricht wie sein Vorgänger
fließend Deutsch zuvor war der
46-Jährige Sonderbeauftragter der
Ukraine für Sanktionen gegen Russland
im Norden Myanmars wurden während eines
Konzerts bei Luftangriffen des Militärs
mindestens 80 Menschen getötet das
Konzert sollte an die Gründung einer
unabhängigkeitsorganisation erinnern
berichten lokale Medien die ethische
Minderheit der katschin dort fordert
mehr Rechte und Selbstbestimmung Anfang
vergangenen Jahres hatte das Militär in
Myanmar geputscht die Hunter unterdrückt
jeden Widerstand
zurück nach Deutschland wie kommen wir
durch den corona-herbst und Winter
darüber berieten heute die
Gesundheitsminister der Länder
schließlich ist es nach dem
Infektionsschutzgesetz Sache der Länder
zum Beispiel die maskenregeln wieder zu
verschärfen die Amtsärzte fordern wie
vermutlich viele ein einheitliches
Vorgehen Haken Nikolas hat mehr
entfernt Verkehr von Bus und Bahn gilt
bundesweit maskenpflicht so gibt es der
Bund im Infektionsschutzgesetz vor
andere öffentliche Bereiche wie die
Gastronomie Regeln die Bundesländer
bislang uneinheitlich Sachsen-Anhalt
etwa setzt auf maskenempfehlung und zu
reichend finden die Amtsärzte
angesichts-ziffer
das möglichst klar wird
wenn die Inzidenz bei 500 oder 1000 ist
dann dass man sowohl in Hamburg als auch
in München gleich vorgeht dass das
Wesentliche dass da also nicht eine
Polyphonie eine Vielstimmigkeit dann
weiter besteht Regelungsbedarf bestehe
auch im Gesundheitsbereich die
maskenpflicht in alten- und Pflegeheimen
finden Patientenvertreter
unverhältnismäßig zudem müssen nun im
dritten Corona Herbst die Impfpflicht im
Gesundheitswesen Enden stattdessen soll
er es mehr Tests geben
ein testregime das intelligent umgeht
mit PCR-Test und Schnelltest ist ein
effizientes Mittel um mit Corona zu
leben insbesondere dann wenn es sich um
pflegebedürftige vulner haben eine
schwerstgabe Menschen handelt das kostet
natürlich Geld aber das muss die
Bundesregierung bereitstellen Beschlüsse
zu all dem Fasten die
Gesundheitsminister heute nicht zu
unterschiedlich die Positionen auch beim
Thema maskenpflicht in Innenräumen die
Länder haben unterschiedliche Meinungen
zu diesem Thema klar ist wenn es zu
einer Maske im Innenraum kommen sollte
dann möchte man schon einheitlich
versuchen das auszusteuern nun will man
auf Arbeitsebene beraten das nächste
Treffen der Gesundheitsminister ist im
Dezember geplant
der Ruf der
bundeswehreliteeinheit KSK ist nach
rechtsextremistischen Vorfällen
angeschlagen heute besuchte die
Verteidigungsministerin das Kommando
Spezialkräfte um zu sehen ob die
verordneten Reformen fruchten einige
Soldaten hatten sich in rechtsextremen
chatgruppen ausgetauscht sie wollten die
staatliche Ordnung zerstören und dann
die Macht übernehmen im Mai 2020 fand
die Polizei bei einem KSK-Soldaten in
Sachsen Schusswaffen und Sprengstoff wie
der eliteverband sich heute präsentiert
zeigt Konstanze Kainz
schnelle Schritte scharfe Schüsse
Übungen des KSK unter Beobachtung der
Verteidigungsministerin von ihr gibt es
danach Anerkennung die Frauen und Männer
beim KSK haben mein vollstes Vertrauen
dabei war die Spezialeinheit in Verruf
geraten Rechtsextremismus versteckte
Munition und verschwundener Sprengstoff
die Antwort der damaligen
Verteidigungsministerin Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer ein 60 Punkteplan ihre
Nachfolgerin bescheinigt heute diese
Maßnahmen sind umgesetzt und es wird ein
weiterer Prozess sein ist also nicht so
dass es jetzt schluss ist sondern es
wird immer wieder eben auch evaluiert
werden waffenbestände werden nun
beispielsweise strenger kontrolliert
eines Skandal umwitterte kompanie wurde
aufgelöst es geht voran so der
Bundesvorsitzende der Grünen
Spezialkräfte gebraucht werden es ist
richtig und bekannt dass da jetzt sehr
viel passiert ist damit die Probleme der
Vergangenheit behoben werden auch ob das
erreichen wird das wird sich auf der
Strecke es weisen doch Lambrecht ist
Zuversicht der Elite Verband sei wieder
auf Kurs eine Einschätzung die Kritiker
nicht teilen so wird der Klaps der ein
Buch über das KSK geschrieben hat ich
habe das Gefühl die Ministerin will
Verein rüberbringen dass Kritik an der
an den kommandozialkräften nicht mehr
angebracht ist dass man weitermachen
wenn die Zukunft gucken will das ist
sozusagen Schwamm drüber es wurden
Fehler gemacht aber die sind vergessen
damit man sich jetzt eben auf die
aktuellen Probleme konzentrieren kann
aber genauso funktioniert es eben nicht
Skepsis und Zuversicht nach dem ersten
Besuch der Verteidigungsministerin beim
Kommando Spezialkräfte
so wenige Autodiebstähle wie im
vergangenen Jahr gab es in Deutschland
noch nie unter 10.000 die Versicherer
mit und damit 8% weniger als im Jahr
zuvor abgesehen haben es Autodiebe
besonders auf SUVs und das vor allem in
Berlin laut Polizei dominieren Banden
aus Osteuropa den Autodiebstahl
Boris Palmer bleibt für weitere acht
Jahre Tübingens Oberbürgermeister wegen
innerparteilichen zoffs war er nicht für
die Grünen angetreten sondern als
unabhängiger Kandidat und holte die
absolute Mehrheit die Mitgliedschaft
Palmers bei den Grünen Ruth bis Ende
2023 wegen Streits um Tabubrüche und
Rassismus Vorwürfe
es gibt auch in diesen Zeiten Menschen
die viel Geld für Kunst ausgeben zum
Beispiel auf der wichtigsten Messe für
gegenwandskunst der Art Basel die gab es
jetzt zum ersten Mal in Paris vier Tage
lang mit gewaltigen Erfolg
Menschenmassen schoben sich durch die
Gänge innerhalb weniger Stunden gab es
Verkäufe in Millionenhöhe Thomas Walde
berichtet
die Galerie sprüht Magers aus Berlin
reiste mit Werken von Reinhard Mucha an
eine von 156 die bei der neuen Messe
unter dem Eiffelturm einen der begehrten
Plätze bekamen
es ist das erste Mal Art Basel in Paris
das heißt es ist viel Neugier da es sind
sehr sehr viele internationale Besucher
in Paris Art Basel steht für Umsatz die
Zusammenarbeit mit dieser Marke soll
Paris zum Zentrum des Kunsthandels
machen und die bisherige Spitze in
Europa verdrängen
[Musik]
brexit hat London mehr geschadet als
Paris direkt genutzt aber eröffnet den
Weg für eine neue kulturelle Hauptstadt
Europas
der Lauf der Welten heißt dieses Werk
von Alicia gerade ausgestellt auf
plasmondom und die Welten die sich hier
begegnen heißen Kunst und Luxus Sammler
und Galeristen bringen viel Geld in
Boutiquen und fünf Sterne Hotels
seit der Ankunft der erdbasel haben wir
eine Zunahme der Buchungen gesehen von
internationalen und vor allem
europäischen Gästen
zahlreiche Galerien berichten von sehr
guten Verkäufen in den vergangenen Tagen
es ist eine besondere Welt die Paris für
fast eine Woche zu ihrer Hauptstadt
erklärte eine Welt in der Krieg
Energiekrise und Strom sparen weit weg
zu sein scheinen
jetzt zum Handball auch erfolgreich im
Handball Magdeburg freut sich hat wieder
die Club WM gewonnen ja der
Titelverteidiger hat geliefert in der
packenden Neuauflage des
vorjahresendspiels gewann er SC gegen
Champions League Sieger Barcelona knapp
mit 41 zu 39 nachverlängerung zum
fünften Mal geht die Club WM-Krone an
ein deutsches Team
leichtes Spiel haben sie nicht den
Finale des Turniers in Saudi-Arabien
Magdeburg bringt einen sechs Tore
Vorsprung nicht über die Zeit sieben
Sekunden vor Schluss gleich Campus Wanne
für Barcelona aus Philipp Weber verfehlt
dann das Ziel mit der Schlusssirene 10
Minuten Verlängerung das Spiel steht auf
der Kippe
da taucht der Schwede Wanne erneut an
der sieben Meter Marke auf diesmal
hält Nicola Portner der Schweizer Keeper
des SCM kurz darauf erzielt Magdeburgs
bester Werfer der East in der Oma in die
Magnusson das entscheidende 41 zu 39
die gut 400.000 Euro Preisgeld für den
vereinsweltmeister gehen nach Magdeburg
[Applaus]
Hertha BSC stürzt die Schalker noch
tiefer in die Krise durch das 2:1
gestern gegen die Königsblauen die damit
auf den letzten Tabellenplatz rutschen
ja und faustdicke Überraschung im
anderen Sonntagsspiel der VfL schlägt
Union den Keller Kindern aus Bochum
gelingt mit dem Tor von Gerrit Holtmann
in der 71 Minute das entscheidende 2:0
danach verschießt der Tabellenführer
durch Milos pantovic einen Elfer der
Berliner kann später in der 90 Minute
nur noch zum 1 zu 2 Endstand verkürzen
und alle Spiele alle Tore alle
Highlights des 11 bundesligaspieltags
bei uns zusammengefasst zu sehen bei ZDF
heute.de und in der ZDF heute App
deutscher doppelterfolg beim
kurzbahn-weltcup in Berlin über 800
Meter Freistil der Frauen die 20-Jährige
Europameisterin aus Magdeburg Isabel
Goose gewinnt das Rennen souverän mit
mehr als 8 Sekunden Vorsprung vor ihrer
Teamkollegin Sarah Wellbrock die
28-Jährige gab in Berlin nach langer
Pause ihr internationales Comeback
Magdeburg hat heute einen Lauf ne ja
auch auf Fotos sagen
und jetzt noch ein wenn auch noch nicht
offiziell bestätigter Weltrekord in
Indien feiern die Hindus gerade das
Lichterfest die Walli in der Stadt
aiodia sollen dabei knapp 1,6 Millionen
Öllämpchen entzündet worden sein so
viele wie noch nie zuvor das Lichterfest
ist für Hindus ähnlich bedeutsam wie das
Weihnachtsfest für Christen dabei wird
der Sieg des Lichts über die Dunkelheit
gefeiert
von wegen Ende Oktober es wird in den
nächsten Tagen wärmer die Details hat
gleich aus den terli im heute-journal um
zehn nach zehn freuen sich eine gelinek
und Gundula Gause auf sie wir wünschen
Ihnen einen schönen Abend und danken für
Ihr Interesse bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter bisher war der
Oktober viel zu mild und diese milde
Periode setzt sich fort morgen bis zu 21
Grad denn die Wärme kommt aus dem
Südwesten zu uns teilweise aus
Nordafrika und so steigen die
Temperaturen im Laufe der Woche sogar
noch weiter an ja und dazu gibt es in
der kommenden Nacht shower die ziehen
weiter nach Osten und im Tagesverlauf
gibt es noch im ostenschauer und dann
verschwindet der Regen und wie gesagt in
der Nacht im Westen Regen und der
überquert uns nach Nordosten hin im
Süden bildet sich teilweise Nebel in
Gewässernähe bei Temperaturen von 13
Grad am Niederrhein und sieben Grad am
Alpenrand morgen also erst einmal noch
Schauer nach Nordosten hin und auch
Richtung Schleswig-Holstein sonst
lockert es von Südwesten her auf und vor
allem am Alpenrand gibt es viel
Sonnenschein bei höchsten Temperaturen
bis 21 Grad am Oberrhein und zum
Beispiel 15 Grad an der Ostsee dass die
Temperatur Spanne und die nächsten Tage
werden immer wärmer Mittwoch mit
Schauern zwar noch bis 23 Grad
Donnerstag dann bis 24 und Freitag sogar
25 Grad ein schönen Abend